the latest episode of Watchmen is here
in what the well you know what they say
once you go blue oh god these intros are
getting worse yes another week of
watchmen and another week of tantalizing
new clues to dissect and you're gonna
want to stick around till the very end
because we have some absolutely crazy
theories to get through so strap on in
because here we go we're here in
downtown Tulsa with a character we'll
come to know as Laurie Blake aka the
Silk Spectre former lover of dr.
Manhattan she's using what's called the
blue booth Network which is run by a
company owned by true we'll learn more
about her next episode if you remember
from last episode we see a young girl by
the name of Yin pick up papers for her
boss and my guess is that true is this
person these booths allow people to send
messages to dr. Manhattan and as we'll
learn throughout the episode this scene
although at the beginning of the episode
chronologically takes place at the end
of it the Washington Monument looks like
it has a fancy new tourist trap and we
see this ad for the Minutemen featuring
what appears to be captain metropolis on
the right and either night owl or the
comedian on the left both of them have
the same style of mass but I'll let you
be the judge
outside the bank we see its name a
National Bank company very original
which is the same Bank that employed
dollar bill who is one of the original
Minutemen and who we saw a poster of in
Episode one inside which will later find
out is a sting operation by the
anti-vigilante task force a task force
created by the FBI to stop you guessed
it masked vigilantes we see this guy
holding a paper that says Grisham to
retire from Supreme Court in this
alternate reality the best-selling legal
and crime author John Grisham is a
Supreme Court justice as well come to
learn throughout this episode
Laurie Blake absolutely hates masked
vigilantes she has devoted her life to
stopping them this no doubt a result of
her involvement with the watchman and
dr. Manhattan she takes down a vigilante
known as mr. shadow and is heckled
outside by protesters
Laurie believes these masked vigilantes
although they think they may be doing
good
aren't this is later expanded upon in
our talk with Angela men who end up
hanging from trees with secret
compartments in their closets tend to
think of themselves as good guys and
those who protect them I think they're
good guys too
her call to dr. Manhattan is also a
damning portrayal of her former
superhero friends all of whom end up in
Hell in her joke and here we can see
this beautiful Andy Warhol style
painting of them with laurie framed in
the bottom right it seems in this
alternate universe Warhol is still alive
at home she plays DeVos space junk
fitting since the episode is entitled
she was killed by space junk and ironic
since she's almost seemingly killed by
something by space at the end of the
episode we'll get to that in a bit she
takes out a mouse and feeds it to her
owl who likely an homage to her former
partner night owl we have not seen the
second iteration of niteowl yet in the
show but according to the supplemental
material on HBO's website he's in a
federal prison for violating the Keene
Act in 1995 Laurie was also arrested
alongside him but were not sure how she
wasn't sent to jail as well perhaps she
struck some sort of deal but Keene says
if she's able to stop the unrest in
Tulsa and if he were to become president
he'll give her a full pardon we also see
the code for the yes what appears to be
giant dildo is 666 but it cuts right
before it can reach that number which
happens to be the same number in the
briefcase from pulp fiction at FBI
headquarters the deputy director is
going over the 7th cavalry and how they
follow war shacks journal using it as
some sort of manifesto even the cover
art looks similar to the Turner Diaries
a fiction novel written by white
supremacist Andrew McDonald and has
since been used as a neo-nazi manifesto
Laurie offers to go to Tulsa to handle
the situation and take speedy with her a
younger agent who has spent much of his
time making PhD papers about Laurie's
Silk Spectre it's no wonder he ends up
eventually sleeping with her we get a
shot of the millenium clock which is
owned by true industries which ended up
taking over White's company well
likely see more of this next episode but
there is undoubtedly a connection
between it Adrian Veidt and dr.
Manhattan especially considering on its
groundbreaking true used a quote from
the poem
Ozymandias look on my works ye mighty
and despair lorry does a bit of her own
investigating here noticing the
wheelchair tracks at Judds hanging sight
we then see her visit Judds home where
people have left some makeshift
memorials we'll later find this is how
she knows about the hidden compartment
in Judds room also this image is just
plain cool lorry finds looking glass in
the rest of the Tulsa PD who have
rounded up residents from Nixon Ville
and are being put through the pod or as
Laurie likes to call it the racist
detector looking glass is using it to
eliminate suspects in Judds murder bonus
points if you caught the squid in the
background
Laurie learns that no toxicology report
was done on Judd likely because Angela
and lookingglass knew he had a few
glasses of wine and lines of coke they
wouldn't want to sully his image outside
the black freighter in we get another
great shot at the world building that's
going on in this show it appears all the
cars run on electricity and even the gas
station in the back here has been
blocked out perhaps out of business the
black freighter is a pirate comic book
magazine within the Watchmen graphic
novel and it isn't the last pirate
imagery we'll see this episode notice
all these giant structures in the back
which I'm not entirely sure are for my
best guess is perhaps power generation
but let me know in the comments below if
you know Laurie loads her gun the same
one which he'll later used to take down
the terrorists and we see she has Case
Files on many of the Tulsa PD the name
of the graveyard here Tartarus acres is
a nod to Greek mythology Tartarus being
the deep abyss used as a dungeon of
torment and a prison for the Titans
yikes there are also a bunch of
protesters outside with songs like real
heroes don't wear masks and give us our
guns back which point to the hostile
environment that has been created that
Keane wants to quash at the funeral
Judds coffin is draped in the new
American flag which features 51 states
including Vietnam Angela sings the last
roundup from the 1941 film the singing
Hill
or the last
when the music is cut short by a suicide
bomb wielding terrorists from this
seventh cavalry he's wanting to take
keen as a hostage because he's seen as a
race trader but before he can get away
Lorie shoots him prompting Angela to
push the body into the grave with Judds
coffin on top of it this will now make
it impossible for Laurie to conduct a
toxicology report with his body exploded
into smithereens now there is just
something about Keane and mrs. Crawford
that rubs me the wrong way I can't help
but think they are connected to the 7th
Calvary and I think for sure Joe Keens
father was a member of the KKK and
likely Judds father too hence their
family's relationship with one another
still I'm keeping my eye on this Keane
guy something just doesn't seem right I
don't know about you guys but these
Ozymandias scenes are my favorite and
our chock-full of mysteries to unlock it
starts with a shot of Aussies purple
mask which will later see him dawn he is
hard at work on plans for a machine that
will help him escape his imprisonment
using Phillips as a test dummy that
doesn't seem to be working here we see a
miniature catapult and later a brief
glimpse of the real one which seems to
be used to catapult its subject into a
different dimension with the body
returning completely frozen solid
most likely in some sort of space hence
the oxygen and body freezing perhaps
they are on some sort of dome on Mars
that Manhattan is operating hence
Manhattan destroying Adrian's castle on
Mars several years in the future Veidt
needs a thicker skin so he travels
beyond the marked territory where he is
not allowed to go to kill a buffalo
which are not native to England or
Europe where he appears to be trapped
but as I've said in my previous videos
this could be an alternate dimension
that he's trapped in but now it's
looking more like it could be some sort
of Ozymandias prison he's nearly killed
by a man we'll come to know as the game
warden a man who addresses Aussie as his
master in his letter leading me to
believe this is also a Philips clone or
perhaps the original my theory so far
that these clones are actually provided
to Adrian by dr. Manhattan and that he
is being imprisoned by Manhattan for
what he did to him ozzie is warned if he
tries to breach his contract and go
beyond his area he will be shot dead
which is when we see him change into
Ozymandias suit and we get confirmation
that he is indeed Adrian Veidt notice
also when Ozzy comes storming home the
three candles on the anniversary cake
each episode has been gaining a candle
leading me to believe they are all three
years apart each year celebrating a year
he's been in captivity in the
quote-unquote real world we heard Adrian
has died so as possible these scenes
happen years ago and they will
eventually catch up to present-day Keene
addresses the crowd and we get an
interesting bit of information that the
Russians are building an intrinsic field
generator the same device that turned
Jon Osterman into dr. Manhattan in the
mausoleum lorry brings Angela a coffee
and basically confronts her about what
she's been doing
she knows Angela took juds KKK robes and
has been snooping around she doesn't
trust good guys
I hate good guys for breakfast the last
image of this scene is Laurie frame
through the lens of these Nite Owl esque
glasses her past and never seeming to
get away from her back at the end Laurie
opens the briefcase to reveal the blue
dr. Manhattan pleasure device while the
voice-over finishes up her joke that
she's been telling throughout the course
of the episode her joke is essentially
her way of expressing her feelings
toward night-owl Adrian Veidt and dr.
Manhattan the three who were gifted with
valuable powers who ended up going to
hell because they squandered them the
little girl in the story the one who
threw the brick up in the air that
eventually kills God was her someone so
jaded about the world
she killed God and where does God go
when he does he goes to hell this is a
one-way conversation she's having with
dr. Manhattan she misses him knowing
he'll probably never hear the message
but she says it's nice to pretend she
says about humanity oh we're not really
worth getting [ __ ] about anyway
which is a great encapsulation of where
we can see her character are going
either she's going to see the error of
her ways and embrace humanity or venture
further from it leading to her own
destruction as she comes out of the
booth a car comes crashing down from the
sky right in front of her and she bursts
out laughing this is dr. Manhattan
responding to her joke with his own
hence why she laughs looking up at the
tinge of orange glow from Mars in the
sky notice also know flying spaceship
here like the one that picked up will at
the end of last episode this was done by
something more supernatural we're only
three episodes in and new mysteries keep
on coming I hope you'll like and
subscribe as I come out with Watchmen
videos every week I also want to hear
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below or you can follow me on
twitter at think story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much